Charles has already built a warp engine
in his basement
I was wondering what you think is the
biggest obstacle for developing working
warp drive and would you see this
becoming a reality and if yes when the
thing that is most blocking our ability
to quit create a warp drive quickly is
physics the actual ability to travel
faster than light at this point we don't
have it when we're going to have it
next Wednesday next Wednesday at 3 pm
according to reliable sources the date
is April 5th 2063. that is according to
Star Trek first Contact
that event happened on April 5th 2063.
okay well there it is then we got it wow
I gotta tell you that was amazing
reality imitating uh art and yeah make
that happen